we've just made an interactive envision
prototype well done remember though the
vital part of prototyping is iteration
and constant improvement we got some
feedback at the end of the last lesson
and we decided on a few potential
changes it's now time to implement those
changes in our interactive prototype Jay
can you remind me what those changes
were yeah the main feedback we received
revolved around the task functionality
not being clear Carl suggested making
the main screen be our day screen which
had the checkboxes we also decided that
would be best to have those checkboxes
have some higher visibility and visual
weight finally we decided that our
wording around task and events was
unclear remember we had intended for
them to be the same object but we've
used two different words for them